what a beautiful masterpiece
i knew she would be such a great artist
right north
when it comes to her kids kim kardashian
has
four words for you don't mess with me
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot
on monday kim hit up instagram to share
this pic of her daughter north's
impressive oil painting and well
the haters did what the haters do and
started questioning whether or not the
seven-year-old
actually painted the landscape herself
but kim she was having none of that
i'm really freaking out and on tuesday
she shared
this lengthy message on her insta story
which read in part quote
don't play with me when it comes to my
children i feel like we are so blessed
to have the best support system and the
best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
the 40-year-old mama of four explained
that north and her best friend had been
taking a painting class where their
talents and creativity were being
encouraged and nurtured and she said it
took her daughter
several weeks to complete the final
product quote
i'm seeing op-ed pieces in the media and
social media from grown adults
breaking down whether or not my child
actually painted this
how dare you see children doing awesome
things and then try to accuse them of
not being
awesome and if that wasn't enough she
wrapped up the whole thing telling
people to stop embarrassing themselves
with the negativity
and allow every child to be great kim
also shared north's friend ryan's
painting from the same class
and she reminded us that back in the day
for kim's first mother's day ever
and then baby north went full-on bob
ross
and finger-painted a very pricey hermes
bag for her mama
i always wanted to look at this
masterpiece guys
this bag north painted for me
when she was not even one years old
what a beautiful masterpiece i knew she
would be such a great artist
right north she also posted some of her
husband kanye west's artwork that he
created when he was a kid
basically proving that the skills
they're in northeast dna
she's a gemini so she's a little bit of
both she definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend
and then she's also really calm and
sweet like me sometimes
you